hello guys it's ryan right here hey guys
i'm andrew and drew twitter.com slash a
course 711 and the channel on youtube
movie source promoting friends that's
what I do best
we're gonna check out the apart 2
trailer for daredevil season 2 there's a
link in the description box for the
first trailer part 1 of this
it's weird part 1 trailer part of a show
that's so [ __ ] strange so there's a
link in the description box for that and
I want to mention I was just on screen
junkies movie fights so go check out
that episode it's the latest movie
fights that's up I like to like the
guest talk it's my favorite thing to do
but you believe it
I said honest
[Music]
I need your help with you you're the
only person I can trust
sweetheart you don't break into my house
and then talk to me about trust that
love meant a lot for me
your fight better than anyone right now
but I have information
the Yakuza never left
that's impossible
I drove them out of New York City no you
didn't
they're just hibernated and watch you
take out all of their enemies
now New York is right for the taking we
do this
nobody device understand hangry oh [ __ ]
the red eyes those stairs
I wonder today's the day you're dead in
your living room there are horrible
things happening in the city apologizing
to you for who I am
this isn't your city anymore
[Music]
waste work
has become here there's nothing we can
do right there I'm cold
oh [ __ ] the hand you cannot stop what we
have started the rising is coming
[Music]
you've been working out by the way I
appreciate that
like I should saying that as you're
seeing a french fry yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] what's her [ __ ] problem
right you can't be a hypocrite like that
you know like what you're judging ever
you used to be a little bit out of shape
come on
on a serious note I'm genuinely excited
or this house looks really [ __ ] sweet
daredevil is one of my all-time favorite
shows right after breaking bad enough
I'd honestly say that you know like it's
not because I'm like like a Marvel freak
I just really love the show one thing
I'm already getting from this trailer I
really like what they did was they kind
of they show like glimpses of the
Punisher but they never made it about
the punish yeah it's more
electronegative it was nice to feel like
yeah but beyond that it was also
Daredevils trailer and the other
trailers it's been like the butter jar
and then this got me jacked up again for
a daredevil himself because you know
like I was really jacked up for the
Punisher but watching this trailer
reminded me just how much I love the
character daredevil absolutely and not
only that like I said it was more
Elektra having in terms of Frank castle
from last Raylan we get to see you know
what the storylines are gonna be in the
tone for this season you know he's
obviously he's gonna be dealing with
Frank Castle cuz you know Frank doesn't
feel that he's you know the force that
gets things done in the city so yeah
that's why he has to come in with
electric at least from what we're seeing
in this trailer it looks like she needs
his help fighting you know either that
yet the Yakuza or the hand or whatever
they hand and even look like possibly
that was Nobu who is coming back with
that I can tell but maybe that's it was
from season one and I love that
character in the few episodes we got
them and the action scenes between him
and Matt Murdock I'm really hoping
that's him that's come back when we
first see them they just just strikes
when they have a really good chemistry
together you know the banter between
them it looks like I mean because we he
alluded in season one or at least in the
flyer him and foggy were talking that he
had a Greek girlfriend in college so
obviously that's a lecture they were
alluding to so it looks like just from
the first scene we see in this you know
that they were a couple who you know
I've known each other for years so I
just I get the feeling from them
that just from what and I love that
dynamic I know in the daredevil movie
and then they even had a spinoff of
electro Rob Bowman to us about their to
the phone data lecture portrayal
whatever with this though I'm already
liking this electric portrayal a lot
more I'm gonna make it clear don't know
the comics of Elektra
however as just from a trailer I'm Mike
this one seems much more interesting
than the Jennifer Garner approach that I
saw before this Elektra you know she's
foreign and I like the history of what
you're talking about because you feel
the sense of Darkness but love between
the two I feel like there might be some
childhood history to them as well
you know maybe they came across a
similar mentor down the road cuz I know
Matt Murdock had stick but stick left
and pretty early on so maybe he had
another mentor along the way and that's
how he sort of got to know like I don't
know this story
yeah but what I love from the trailer is
it's getting me thinking and wondering
and this is what's I'm coming up with in
my head and also just add after what you
saying that I want to see some visual
flashbacks of them together you know
maybe show a few scenes you know them in
college or maybe [ __ ] like you just said
her training him a little bit even or
yeah I'm training together I definitely
want to see some a lot look if they give
us a dialogue you know oh I'll take it
you know but I like visual flashbacks
bet more you know and they don't have to
be drawn out long but just a few scenes
you know where I can see their history
you know I'd rather feel history then
see or hear about it but if you're gonna
choose between seeing and hearing about
it I'd rather see it electors explain
how the Yakuza never left
and how daredevil just sort of took out
all their enemies that's pretty
interesting you know a because that's
kind of what it's like dealing with the
criminal underworld every criminal like
the organization's they all have enemies
so daredevil can go after one enemy but
then that leaves room for the other
enemy to go in there so it's like it
makes the mission of daredevil feel even
more impossible to reach yet this
character keeps on reaching like how the
[ __ ] can you clean up Hell's Kitchen
yeah you know with all that I mean take
out one organization it makes another
organization bigger
clearly this is a job for the defenders
and the defenders are daredevil Luke
Cage Jessica Jones and Iron Fist who has
just cast an actor from Game of Thrones
by the way but just getting back to your
point now I agree with you and also it
made me feel a little bit like I mean
this is said in the MCU which they've
made clearly stated in this first season
I felt like it was a little bit of like
Hydra you know like you cut off the head
of a snake and you know two more shell
you know arise so it just felt felt like
like you said if you you know beat that
bet to that you know group or
organization another one's gonna gonna
you know get bigger have an opening and
as we saw in the first season the
dynamic between all those organizations
you know Wilson Fisk and Nobu and those
I forgot the lady I just I mean yeah she
was she was actually kind of menacing in
the first thing that she's clearly an
Iron Fist villain and they were giving
us that connection in the defenders but
just again you can see like they all
wanted Hell's Kitchen for themselves and
when one person seems we call I'm taking
it yeah because when I remember like any
time they felt Wilson Fisk had us a
moment of weakness and they felt Vanessa
was as you know weakness last season
they were trying to exploit that and
take advantage of it so I you make a
really good explanation their point and
the more I'm seeing of the suit the more
I'm liking it yeah you know like we got
the glimpse of his red eyes which was
like oh like that it was like that means
white eyes yeah exactly that I love how
companies are now making the intentional
effort to actually throw in like a cool
thing you know you're Devils I mean a
Deadpool's eyes - yeah amazing yeah yeah
yeah so seeing daredevil in the costume
and moving and stuff I was like all
right so we're gonna get some cool
action scenes between him and Elektra
working together
I imagine Elektra at some point stops
working side by side with him and maybe
starts like because cuz they're gonna
have a clash of four principles they're
gonna have a clash of point-of-view even
said no killing no killing but you're as
you can see like she's not against that
then there's the Punisher who's coming
over who she might side with so it's
it's gonna make a lot of interesting
dynamics I'm super stoked for it it
actually focal hot like Dark Knight
Rises and turns yes Batman and Catwoman
team yup no guns no killing and how the
city is truly like yeah could be coming
to an end and then you're and also your
leg understanding
even though they're working together
they're gonna clash at some point that
line that he says when they're there are
horrible things happening in the city
but I'm done apologizing for Who I am
I'm happy to hear a [ __ ] hero say
that to their whiny best friend you know
like anytime I see that character in a
show or a movie who's always like like
that's what Dark Knight Rises that's
kind of what I hated about what they do
with Alfred they made him that whiny
friend who's like instead of supporting
the hero they're constantly kind of
making them feel guilty about being the
hero you know
so if foggy you know sort of turning
into that character at least that's what
the trailer alludes to it's cool to see
the hero taking a stand like that that's
a best friendship and they're treating
the writing is treating it like a French
interview yeah so if they're arguing
like real friends and he's talking to
him like a real friend instead of just
like stemming like a badass yeah you
made a perfect point about daredevil I
mean he's explained to fly you so many
times why he does what he does and on
and now to go to foggy side like his his
explanation makes sense to you like he
doesn't want to see his best friend get
hurt and he understands what he's doing
but that's just not again he's he's
being a little selfish in terms of you
he doesn't want his best friend you know
to get to get murdered and get killed
and he keeps seeing him every time he
comes back he's more bloody and more
hurt so you know he's just concerned for
him so even though you more side with
Matt in this particular argument you
completely understand foggy it's not
like do doggies Adaline here what an
idiot no he's a good best friend you'd
be an idiot if he said have fun later
Matt well foggy really wants Matt to
fight along the side of the law you know
really work in there and they're
loitered cases there yeah dances in
stuff you know daredevil of course feels
like that doesn't always work the show
does a good job at making things go
worse when daredevil participates yeah
that it kind of makes you question
should he just stick to law but then it
goes back to making dirt so this this
show is good at making you yourself go
should he really be doing this because
I'm watching trend I'm like it kind of
seems like you made things a little
worse because now the city is just like
everyone's remembering that and I'm and
again I hate going back and making you
know Christopher Nolan Batman things but
again it felt like a little you know
with Batman you know we're
kind of creates the Joker in terms of
you know escalation you know or you know
it's gonna get worse before it gets
better and I think that's kind of the
case here where you know even though
there are you know crazy relations even
though you you are questioning is not
making it worse like it's still gonna be
this bad you know if he's not there so
might as well be there to you know
defend the city and again I'm not
getting on the show for you know copying
a few things from Dark Knight of the
visuals I love it those are good things
to copy on if you're going to copy ons
they made amazing interesting points and
say copy oh that's the insight sorry
inspired yeah I'm not saying copying you
know what I mean I know what the YouTube
world might not open I know what you
mean they take everything you say it's
really so comparing daredevil to
Marvel's other best character hey hey
badan Affleck is playing Batman I have a
right to do and he played dared oh just
kidding but that is true and you're
interrupting my joke for your thing oh
sorry man what was your joke that Batman
was part of the Marvel Universe
and I was gonna keep going off he is
though right I wasn't planning on
working with that part I thought you
were gonna just nod your head oh sorry I
feel like the theme of should you kill
or not is really been elevated because
with the city going just [ __ ] to like
bananas right now it makes more sense to
me why the Punisher stepping in you know
you just sent some other people to jail
like then this other organization gets
bigger it's like no you've got to
eliminate the threat I'm even feeling
that right now like it no daredevil
you've got a kill man like you have to
that's what's making this really
interesting to me because even now just
from a trailer I'm going I think he
should kill holy you know yeah it's it's
at that point oh yeah not only then we
see this worldís I mean the universe
that they've created the Hell's Kitchen
it's so corrupt it's you know I mean so
you know there's a good argument to be
made even though I don't think daredevil
is ever gonna go down that line yeah
it's definitely interesting to talk
about because you see as you do as he
pointed out many times when he defeats
one organization he just gave another
organization more more bigger party to
the hell's kitchen's now I mean it's a
good theory and argument you know does
they're double need to kill to really
eliminate Knights and I think Punisher
is gonna help us answer that question
and the justice system is so corrupt in
house kitchen oh yeah it's like you send
them to jail it doesn't realize a bucket
or matter okay so you have to kill and
like it's cool having the Punisher be in
here and one thing I'm hoping too is
that when the Punisher and daredevil
like do decide to be friends I hope it's
not done in some cliche way I would like
the cause for them to be together and
like be friends or work together to be
something that is different then oh
there's a much bigger enemy right here
little more together
I thought at the end of this trailer
Punisher and daredevil we're gonna look
at Elektra and say she with you I
thought she was with you but I get wrong
wrong trailer right just keep comparing
this to Batman uh I got Marvel's
favorite hey going off your point man
get something around to be natural you
gonna rub me again I can't promise that
vengeance will not take place who said
that I said it doesn't mean that [ __ ] up
it sound pretty cool though right yeah I
was badass
yeah that's a badass see I'm like foggy
I say enjoy your embrace it yeah that
would race I need a friend with a
superhero too so but you know I have
taken selfies yeah if you guys are new
to the channel you can subscribe today
become a reject naming fans is so Andrew
a Gore 7-eleven on Twitter and movie
source YouTube channel has a lot of
reviews up there I recently
guest-starred in their Deadpool analysis
video so you should check that out and
follow us on the Facebook's the
instagrams and the Twitter's and I want
to give a shout out to a guy named
Jonathan Peck he really petitioned to
get me on movie if I had to know a lot
of you guys did but he would he really
like went out of his way and screenshot
a conversation he had with Andy signor
so thank you man your support means a
lot and hopefully one day you will have
a relationship with two women at the
same time because it'll be great hopping
back and forth
between the sexes eventually they'll
both find out you'll regret it you'll
hate yourself but down the road you'll
learn to love yourself and settle down
with just one woman and realize you want
a monogamous relationship BAM the life
and story of Andrew that's your story
now